okay there is a ton of disinformation
and straight-up propaganda floating
around about coronavirus so I want to go
over the actual science around cures
treatments and vaccines that are being
investigated what's most promising
timelines etc before we jump in remember
drinking silver won't cure coronavirus
prayer won't cure or prevent coronavirus
buying a two-year supply of toilet paper
certainly won't help black people aren't
immune as was floating around this is
not a Chinese bioweapon created in
partnership with Kim jong-un we'll get
to that this is a virus and as such we
can look at vaccines antivirals and
antibodies and then in the meantime the
treatment of symptoms and of course
social isolation in order to prevent
transmission the treatment of symptoms
of course includes things like breathing
assistance through ventilators and other
things that can be done while the body
is attempting to fight the virus off
naturally let's first talk about
vaccines vaccines take a while to
develop there is a large range being
cited for how long it might take until a
vaccine is ready for public use you have
to get through development clinical
trials approval production distribution
there are some vaccines that are ready
for trials the timeline that is most
realistic for a vaccine being ready
optimistically we're looking at eight
months less optimistically looking at 18
to 24 months sort of at the most
conservative zero is already a vaccine
from the Israeli mEagle Galilee
Institute because they've had a poultry
coronavirus vaccine for a while they've
modified it to be a human version it
should be ready to test any day but
again the testing is the beginning of a
very long process there's a bunch of
other vaccines and development subject
to the same timeline the vaccine is of
course for people not yet sick in order
to make them immune no vaccine is 100%
the idea is if lots of people get it you
can build herd immunity reduce what's
called r0 or are not two below one
meaning one person
is infecting no more than one other
person on average right now the are not
of kovat 19 is between one point four
and three point nine and obviously until
we get that below one we will continue
to have more cases second antivirals
kovat nineteen is a virus not a bacteria
so antibiotics would not work against it
antivirals are used to treat viral
infections antibiotics go in and destroy
the bacteria antivirals instead tend to
prevent the virus from developing
replicating or spreading there's a few
promising ones being tested
they all have their side effects one is
called the rim des aveer it's made by
Gilead Sciences it was developed for
Ebola didn't really work well for Ebola
it's being tested in clinical trials
right now including I believe in South
Korea now there are conflicting reports
about how well it's working there was a
report last week saying it's working
well other reports saying it's not
really clear it's working better than
placebo and it has significant side
effects in a large portion of patients
we just need more data
maybe it's an antiviral that could be
modified to better work on kovat 19 with
fewer side effects there's another
antiviral being tested in Japan called a
vegan now this was actually developed by
Fujifilm and it was developed as a
broad-spectrum flu antiviral that Japan
stockpiled and it can have serious side
effects up to and including birth
defects so women 18 to 40 straight up
shouldn't even be be using it at all
experts think this is probably a began
not going to work well enough to justify
the risks and then we have the
possibility of giving people antibodies
antibodies actually neutralize the virus
pathogen the specific one when you fight
the virus off naturally you develop
antibodies the idea is take the
antibodies from patients who have
recovered and transfuse them into a
serum which you can give to another
patient the issue is the the logistics
are tough because right now the
antibodies you can get from one
patient in the tests that have been done
are enough to give to one patient one to
one is not a great ratio in terms of the
logistical task that's required it's
being looked at
there are also side-effects fever
allergic reactions you can also transmit
infections
that's being tested in China at the
earliest that looks like fall then Dutch
reach researchers have found another
antibody which they say seems to be
working against the virus in lab
settings and could be used to develop an
antiviral it's also early could be
awhile until that is developed so as all
of this comes together what we're
quickly learning is the social
distancing work from home avoid crowds
shut down restaurants going out only for
necessities like groceries and
medications otherwise remaining isolated
that's all we have right now and until
some of these things can be developed we
have to do that unfortunately too many
Americans aren't taking it seriously
I don't want martial law I don't want
police lockdowns that will get very very
ugly so people have to start cooperating
otherwise it's going to get even worse
we'll be continuing to cover this on our
Instagram account follow the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you $5.00 when you sign
up for their completely free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you
can set spending limits you can freeze
them you can delete them anytime you
want so when you do this it means you're
not going to be charged when you don't
want to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a $10 a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman